we all know how modern diplomacy works
with embassies placed in each other's
countries and ambassadors communicating
with heads of governments receiving
their orders from home but how did
medieval diplomacy work and a part of
the medieval period which is
representative is the opening phase of
the Hundred Years War
well first of all there were no
permanent embassies during this period
barring those with the Vatican although
some ambassadors and diplomats were
attached to a Kings Court for a long
period if they were say allies in a war
normally though ambassadors weren't
present until one was sent to deliver a
message these message bearing emissaries
were either members of the nobility or
high-ranking clergymen or if it was
extremely important a member of the
royal family these ambassadors were
given orders in a list of concessions or
demands that they were allowed to make
and much of it was left to their
judgment or capability success would see
promotion and reward whereas failure
would see them earn the Kings
displeasure which was not something
anyone actually wanted now medieval
diplomacy operated within two frameworks
which aren't relevant to modern
international relations
the first was feudalism and the fact
that many leaders owed theity in
allegiance to others for example the
chook of Brittany owed fealty to the
king of France despite being nominally
independent but this didn't stop him
from trying to create his own alliance
with Scotland at the expense of France
also you know Edward the third the King
of England who is Duke of Aquitaine also
owed fealty to the King of France which
in case you're wondering he refused
hence the start of the Hundred Years War
the second framework in which medieval
diplomacy operated was as part of the
Christian word which underpinned
everything including feudalism the
church demanded to be made privy to all
negotiations and the Pope could
theoretically veto any proposition or
peace treaty
just like when Scotland asked him to use
that veto to stop France from making a
separate peace with England the Pope
ignored this so one of the most common
diplomatic actions at this time was the
creation of alliances and whilst the
most notable one of the Hundred Years
War was the old alliance between France
and Scotland the one between France a
bohemian oooone and so we'll use that
one as an example alliances were often
secured via the marriage of royal
children to either Nobles or other royal
offspring like when John the heir to the
French throne was married to the
daughter of the Bohemian King the idea
being that the offspring of these
marriages would tie the kingdoms
together permanently
whereas in reality it often just led to
dynastic conflict like the Hundred Years
War the way it worked was that suitors
would be proposed money would be offered
in the terms of the Alliance would be
hashed out over along
period often years so what about
declarations of war well there was no
formal act of declaring war because
frankly there was no need to the reason
being that medieval warfare took a long
time to get started raising an army
required word to be sent across the
kingdom to rally the troops this would
get noticed pretty quickly by merchants
of spies and relayed to the party that
was about to be invaded and us for peace
treaties these involved ambassadors
traveling to the court to make turns but
sometimes they didn't even have to
travel that far such as for king john ii
of france in 1360 because he was
currently sitting in in english jail and
so that covers the main forms of
medieval promess ii and how they were
conducted barring church business it was
mostly done slowly through Nobles and
clergymen sent to discuss terms and
report back there were no formal
declarations of war like they were in
the 19th century and much of it was
conducted through the nuance of fealty
which in case you're wondering could be
traded away and one thing that dominated
them was the rights of the church and
Christian valleys which is what made it
most fundamentally different from the
diplomacy of today I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
but thanks to my patreon supporters whom
you can see on screen now plus with an
extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette Danny Maloney cool and
Castleman party boy Co Rob Waterhouse mo
Aaron the white Michael Reynolds Chris
wicker Gustav Swan ash way and Emperor
Gareth Turner David Silverman spinning
three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check a
Spencer Lightfoot Winston k-word Anthony
Beckett Kelly moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike